thank you so much for joining us here
i'm john langley we're about halfway
through now the first day of classes
back at clark county school district the
exciting day featured dr superintendent
dr jesus jarrah all over the valley
welcoming students back on campus our
christian kazadis follow it along
students at matt calley elementary were
welcomed back with a big celebration
this morning many parents standing by as
the new school year begins
it was a back to school like no other
for these students firefighters police
officers and even governor steve sisilak
cheering them on as each one walked
along the red carpet at matt kelly
elementary are you excited
beyond excited we love being able to
welcome our babies back to school the
first day of school for ccsd began
before sunrise at the arville
transportation yard near arville and
harmon bus drivers there getting ready
to pick up students along the 1384
routes and preparing for any issues i've
got to watch out for not only kids but
parents cutting through the street and
then cars doing new terms this is an
entire enterprise you know you get a
fleet of 7 300
you know buses and routes you have
you know meals we serve 41 million meals
here in the valley in our community for
our kids you know you have our educators
you got our support staff back at matt
kelly elementary students were welcomed
with backpacks and snacks as he walked
on campus while parents watched i'm
trying not to cry but she said i got
this she didn't even want me to walk on
campus it made them excited to even come
back for the first day because i know
when i went to school they didn't do all
this the principal of the school tells
us the celebration was very important on
this first day of school she says it's a
reminder that all students and staff are
important and teamwork is crucial to
make the new school year a successful
one christian gossip is live local now
and moments ago dr jarrah gave a bit of
a wrap up of the morning so far he says
that of roughly 320 000 students across
ccsd about 291 thousand showed up today
dr jarrett also said 90 percent of the
buses were on time we